booth
que s'est-il passé hier soir je n'avais
jamais fait un rêve aussi troublant
c'était comme revenir au monde remonte
et respirer la lumière leur temps mon
visage ses hurlements mon coeur qui bat
bon
oh
betty qu'est ce qui peut bien mal
c'est inexplicable après avoir été
exposés à une telle dose de rayons gamma
vous devriez être bon vous êtes bien
vivre peut-être parce que t'es pas tout
à fait comme moi il ya trop de choses
qui vous échappent à demoiselle ross mon
fils est unique et parce qu'il est
unique
le monde ne lui pardonnera pas d'exister
mon proche
je pense que la colère est à l'origine
des mutations
n'est ce pas un peu tiré par les cheveux
et un moment que nous avons franchi ce
stade si tu veux mon avis nous avons
offert un monstre hop c'est un être
humain pas un monstre je vais
l'isolément occupé moi même et je le
tuerais avant qu'il ne commette
l'irréparable
tu serais vraiment prêts à détruire une
partie de toi même ça j'en doute
à
tu m'as trouvé
c'était pas difficile
avait ce qui m'effraie le plus c'est
quand je ne peux plus jeter quand je
perds tout contrôle
j'adore ça il va falloir que l'on prenne
garde tes humeurs changeantes